do it for the users you know I think way
too many people are asking me well how
do you have so many people following you
why do people care why are people
passionate about the product I think
which so many people are not realizing
in this space and in business in 2008
and Beyond
is that with everything being
transparent and everybody knowing
everything about anything and everything
authenticity is gonna rule the day and
so when people are making products when
you're making a new app when you're
coming out with a new feature or when
you're building your own personal brand
you need to make every decision based on
the user your friends your fans whatever
you want to call them I prefer friends
these days anyway I mean I just don't
understand why people are saying things
like you know they come up with a new
scheme or new business model or a new
app and they're saying themselves oh I
can do this I can monetize this and then
they come out and try to package it as
saying this is for the user
I mean people understand where things
are coming from today guys I mean you
just can't come out with a product that
you think you're gonna monetize or it's
gonna help you globally with your
marketing efforts or you're gonna sell
against it and then come out and say
this is for the user I have a very good
idea if you make stuff for the user and
you do stuff for the user the users
gonna like you try it